MacLaren's entry-level sports series
consists of three vehicles the most
inexpensive one the 540 C casa cool
160,000 euros and was unveiled the same
year as its big brother
the 570s that model offers even better
performance the cars from this series
are the first MacLaren's with mirrors
for makeup and glove compartments
the youngest member of the family the
570 GT is the most practical in everyday
use
[Music]
car test Irvine ho Dyson over says the
Grand Turismo is made for long journeys
that is to say it's a comfortable sports
car with a serious motor that can also
be driven on a race track that's what
the mclaren 570s damn it Cynthia by
McLaren frontrunner tipsy kitty but
that's not all it is
[Music]
I know tells us that this super sports
car for wealthy drivers now even as a
trunk and a back hatch together with the
space in the front end this McClaren has
370 litres of storage room about the
same as a compact car
but the McLaren GT of course reaches its
destination faster and more comfortably
than the 570s that's because of the
reduced spring rates of the front and
back axles they make the 570 GT more
comfortable if less suited to the
racetrack nonetheless it still has the
same power and velocity as its sporty-er
sibling a top speed of 328 kilometers an
hour and 570 horsepower should be enough
for any lead foot although it is 0.2
seconds slower accelerating
one hundred ninety five thousand euros
is a lot of money says I know but this
British super sports car offers a lot of
race car excitement more than the
Porsche 911 Turbo which has a similar
amount of power and a similar price tag
the McLaren with its carbon dominated
interior it's perfect transmission it's
razor sharp steering and its superlative
motor simply screams racecar
the McLaren also screams luxury the red
leather and the carbon fiber decorative
elements are real eye catchers bike as
siblings the GT has control buttons in
the middle to adjust steering and engine
performance
[Music]
the 570 GT comes with a standard set of
eight loudspeakers a Bowers and Wilkins
hi-fi system with 12 speakers and 1280
watts is optional the comfort the
McLaren offers makes it series
competition for Porsches 911 turbo
ultimately the 540 C triumphs in terms
of value for money the trump card of the
570s is its sportiness and the 570 GT is
the most practical member of the series
you
[Music]